I don't know what I don't know I don't
know one step closer to becoming the old
man emoji I'm in the process of drying
my hair silver and I'm very excited
about it what do you think you're gonna
give me your opinion whether I asked you
or not speaking of your opinions it's
time to comment on your comment last
week in my friary I mentioned the idea
of losing Freud I agree and replacing it
with commenting on comments that's not
entirely a plan I will explain the plan
later in this video
gimmick to get you to continue watching
I mean what about this isn't a gimmick
right now let's come on your comments a
shirt over on Twitter
Jess moon new person to person to person
probably don't know when a new person
comments on one of my social media
platforms i grace the crab at a kitchen
so close for all of you that do not know
when new person comments on my social
media platforms I grace the crap out of
them and welcome them to the grace
Helbig family as we all know in this
family you cannot rely on any sort of
consistency just move more like Jess
please don't moon us
you got that one cool butt cheek the
right one then that left one got weird
after you said the aliens did the stuff
you got 99 problems probes you got
probed 99 time and that one but she
couldn't take it would your grace notice
me very subtle big I bought your book
hashtag Grayson style
done could you sue she new person to
person to person Gucci sushi more like
Chanel tuna now that's a handbag I can
get behind
human wish I am on consecutive hour
three of watching grace on my videos
welcome to college kids my parents were
right I'm having the time of my life god
I really hope that this is a spambot and
if you're not a spambot
your username gucci sushi my assumption
of that is that you're like a rich girl
I just love say shame but you've only
ever had sushi from like the good place
at the mall so I think you spending
three hours watching some of my videos
might give you some
effective before you go back to buying a
bunch of Victoria's Secret Pink
sweatpants the word pink always is just
like a little too close to the vagina
area and it's just very suggestive also
what does pink the musician think about
that
I never Wow oh no family named or that
and then Victoria's Secret just stole
her identity
here's Victoria's Secret she's got a
huge [ __ ] coma cases new person to
person to person help my case is more
like story checks out
sorta you were good when target is sold
out on Grayson style I'm ridiculously
proud when I first looked at this full
photo I thought oh my god why is my book
two hundred and nine dollars and then I
realized that that's the price for
rosetta stone and hey here's a little
tip that you won't find in Grayson style
I know how you can get a stone for free
kidney stones neglect your help now
let's go to Facebook hi Facebook Troy
Jones to person to person to person Troy
Jones more like their name sounds like
you're some sort of like really
well-adjusted stuntman in Hollywood was
really successful because he's both very
athletic and dedicated to his work and
also a very well balanced and fair
minded rational human being with a great
sense of humor
human great I like you much better when
you were comedian in wrote comedy now it
just seems everything heat is targeted
for teens and girls I hear my days if
you be with your youtuber fate I guess I
know I'm farming a cord Emma but there
are a million other people talking off
you get a relationship on YouTube you're
better than that so please give us more
answering Stephanie unless generic
YouTube stuff please keep right every
also until a 41 year old straight male
there's no Lauren watcher provide you
Troy
first of all thank you very much for
your 5-year dedication of watching the
videos that's amazing and I am so
thankful for that second of all turns
out I'm a lady and I love making videos
about things that I love I love comedy
I love lady things and so I like
sometimes making videos combining those
two things my goal on the
all over this next year is to really
find a balance between that comedy stuff
and the more personality driven things
but also to stay true to the stuff that
I like to do though you think that I am
catering to teen and millennial females
the truth is I once was a teen and
millennial female and so sometimes I
like talking about the things that do
relate to a version of me my hope is
that you can see that I'm a human being
struggling and trying to enjoy the
things that I'm well that wasn't
symbolic I don't know what is I'm
ultimately end of the day trying to make
sure I can truthfully say to myself that
I enjoy the content that I am putting
out and that I'm really proud of it I
wouldn't change it if I could
so hopefully you find enjoyment in me
enjoying what I do and truth be told
sometimes I shouldn't hate doing
Stephanie you think a lot of people dump
Beauty videos you know what a lot of
people have done in Jersey characters
and sometimes it makes me feel very
unoriginal doing it so sometimes I need
to balance things and this is where I
put my shoulders up because I'm
uncomfortable kind of telling you how I
honestly feel about thanks marvel super
diversity Rosenberg feels more like Mark
Philip YouTube's human grace you have
some thick eyebrows you have some
accurate observations you love hats the
caps lock key on your keyboard works you
were on Facebook and not doing work on
February 20th at 1246 p.m. two can play
at this fact game now let's go to
YouTube that step playground Nicole good
Terra's numbers my personal version to
koga Terrace more like Nicole you down
maybe too many double letters in your
name we can really we get it get that
second see out of there what is
there it's got what abandonment issues
whoa be alone with yourself do you what
it's like this is what it's like when
you're alone with yourself you know good
well I think josh groban looks handsome
always please tell me that this is Josh
Groban's YouTube account talk about Josh
Groban on your Grammy review fashion
video I'll teach you something let's
create a fake account
what's my username Oh Nicole hmm that's
too obvious Josh Groban knows Nicole
with two seats and two L's is an orphan
second Newport University Persian
Isadora Fonseca more like at the door
Hudson yeah I gotta go away from you
so give me like infinity set Kass that
was my impression of the people you hang
out with with people you're the group no
don't stop fried Ari not everyone has
snapchat and I would be kind of unfair
for your subs that don't have it me okay
listen last Friday I asked you guys what
you thought of me getting rid of fried
diary and bringing back commenting on
comments on Friday and you guys were
really split a lot of people loved it a
lot of people hated that idea a lot of
people just wanted me to do what I
wanted to do and what made me happy but
not Troy from Facebook have to read
through a lot of your comments and then
getting extremely overwhelmed by the
realization that I will not please all
of you with any decision that I make
here are my new thoughts about
scheduling Monday is not too deep
Wednesday's review / Hal twos either one
depending on what I'm feeling and who
knows what I could possibly feel ever
I'm capable of this choice and then
Fridays would be some sort of sexy
miscellaneous Friday day meaning I could
do commenting on comments I could do
fried irie if it's been an interesting
week and I feel like vlogging I could do
some sort of sketch character peace Troy
all I want to do is make you happy
Troy I owe you five years but what I
think I need are names for these days of
the week so that we can differentiate
them I used to do sexy Fridays on Friday
and so I don't want to call it sexy
Fridays again but I want it to be fun
and titillating like a rom-com porn
that's not correct at all so I would
love your suggestions on what you think
I should name um the new Friday segment
and then also maybe Wednesday should we
keep Wednesday a name - sure why not
let's just shin throw ideas out there
welcome to this weird cesspool of
wonderful and terrible ideas for example
ok this has been a very long commenting
on comments and I have hardly commented
on many comments so I'm sure you'll be
upset with that I'm very sorry I can't
do anything right
I've been eating raisin bran of my hands
out of the box because TGIF
Wow I hope you enjoyed this video if you
did give it a thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe because I'm excited about
everything that's happening here on this
channel
finding new fun interesting things and
rehashing old things and reinventing
current things and making things for you
ding-a-lings recently I saw that
snapchat of the Millennial boy dancing
and then his wiener balls of its pants
any time you're upset about something
that's happening in your life I suggest
you take a quick second and you watch
what happens that man that's the kind of
content I should be making cat wieners
falling out of pants while dancing at
weddings ah what's that you Troy was
that here with everything alright I'm
stopped thanks for watching guys I'll
see you you know I don't know what what
am i doing am i going to go cella
am I trying to be a dog am i a dog at
Coachella